[Music]
all right so today we are going to talk
about building web apps in Java and it
sounds like everyone here is either a
Java developer or aspiring Java
developer so you're in the right place
is anyone here currently kind of working
on the web mostly yeah I guess everyone
kind of more or less has to do something
on the web every once in a while anyway
so what we're gonna take a look at one
way that we can build web apps in Java
which is pretty cool it's pretty unique
way of building apps first things first
I promised to introduce myself a little
bit better now that I'm up here my name
is Marcus I work as a lead developer
advocate at a company called Baudin I'm
originally from Finland so I'm kind of
familiar with the darkness and the cold
and the beer and the hockey and all of
that stuff here that said I've moved to
California about six years ago so I'm
I've grown weak I've it feels cold
outside now I don't know what's going on
anyway so my job is essentially I go
around to different meetups and
conferences I do online content just try
to get people aware of odd and help them
get started listen to their complaints
and make sure that our dev team fixes
things and builds the right new stuff
today we're gonna cover essentially two
things who are gonna look at a very
quick introduction to Vaught and just
kind of the four core concepts that we
need to understand before we get to
coding and then we'll essentially spend
the rest of the time in our ID building
an app from scratch and just seeing how
it works kind of going around talking to
developers I've realized that the best
language for explaining stuff to
developer is through code it goes like
if I can show you in code how it works
then there kind of just makes more sense
so Bawden besides our one customer who
came over here hello is there anyone
else here who is actively using one at
the moment all right very good so a lot
of new potential here
for those who are not familiar with
baudin it's a set of UI components and
tools that allow you to build web apps
in Java our main focus is on
productivity so we want you as
developers to be productive when you are
building these web applications what we
really want to achieve is that we want
to give you the tools that allow you to
build really great user interfaces for
your end user so we want to enable you
to build really great UX for the end
users by giving you a whole lot of tools
and components that automate a lot of
the kind of difficult to do the right
things throughout our history we've
always been a Java shop we have always
tried to kind of merge together these
two huge ecosystems the Java ecosystem
and the web so we want people to be Java
developers to be able to build apps in a
language that they know and like and
still be able to publish to this huge
ecosystem which is the web so at the
core of everything in Bawden we have
this big set of UI components kind of
all the different building blocks you
would need when you're building an app
from simple things like X fields and
buttons all the way up to like data
grids and things like that we have built
all of these components mobile first
we've paid a lot of attention to things
like accessibility making sure that
people with screen readers can use them
you can navigate them with your keyboard
and so on
so we give you a very high level of
standard kind of when you get started
we've also made these Thema Bowl so
we'll take a look at this later but
essentially you can choose different
parameters configure parameters which
will make these kind of fit into your
look and feel so they don't feel like
they're completely out of place when
you're building an app for your company
all the components that we have are
built using a new set of web standards
called web components essentially what
we're doing is we're defining new HTML
tags for the browser so that means that
these components that we have are also
usable to essentially any front-end
developer if they just wanted to use
these of course since we are here today
at a Java meetup we're going to take a
look at our own Java framework that uses
these
opponents when you use this framework it
gives you two things it gives you a Java
API for them a component based API and
it gives you automated communication
between the server and the browser so
essentially it means that you don't need
to do any kind of requests and responses
you don't need to deal with serializing
data or anything you just define in java
how your UI should look and behave and
all the rest will be automated by the
framework you can easily extend the
framework we're also gonna take a look
at that in a little while
guess this slide is only for for you
there we did a little architectural
overhaul lately essentially we had a
fairly monolithic structure before where
all these components and the Java
connection were all kind of one big
package so if you wanted to use our data
grid and then you had to kind of buy
into using the whole framework now we've
split these into two so if you look at
the examples later on our website you'll
notice that for every component we'll
list how to use it from HTML or how to
use it through the Java API so it's
essentially it run is an open-source
product
to patch you to license so everything
that we're gonna take a look at today is
something that you can just go home and
try and use and you don't have to pay us
anything for it it's really widely used
I think around last time we checked
around 40 percent of Fortune hundred
companies are using it we have a roughly
150,000 developers in our community of
developers so it's a fairly well used
framework especially when it comes to
like larger and our price type of
applications where this kind of dynamic
type safe way of building you ice makes
a lot of kind of sense
all right I've been talking for several
minutes and they're still not code let's
fix that
so before we get to the actual live
coding I want to just go through a
couple of core concepts to make make it
a little bit easier to follow along like
I mentioned everything in Vaadin is a
component so if you want a button you
would instantiate a button object if you
want to have a date picker you
instantiate a date picker and the same
applies to more kind of low-level HTML
things like if you wanted to spend you
could instantiate a span component
you can then decide how you want to have
these components laid out by putting
them into a layout so in our in a very
simple example a vertical layout would
just put all the components on top of
each other horizontal layout would put
them next to each other and if you used
any of the kind of more advanced layout
you would get more advanced
functionality essentially that's the
idea though of course just putting
components on the screen isn't really
enough we need to add some functionality
to our application the way we do that is
by listening to events so any user
interface component a user can interact
with in any way will trigger events when
those things happen so a button we could
add a click listener to it and then
decide what to do when that button gets
clicked in this case we take the value
from the text field we add it to the
layouts underneath and that's it any
component that we make we can map to a
URL in the browser by adding a route
annotation on it typically you would add
a route annotation on a layout where you
could then define the kind of the entire
view these can be nested they can have
parameters that you can capture and so
on
another part of building larger
applications is binding data so
typically when we're building us we have
some sort of data that we got from our
database or from a REST API or somewhere
and we want to put that in a form we
want to do validations things like that
in this very simple example what I have
is a in-line person class here with some
constraints like not empty an email I
have two text fields for the same name
and email and then I'm using this binder
class here which binds those fields to
the properties on that person object in
this kind of convention based way that
I'm using right here it'll look at the
names and match by them if you want to
be more explicit you can tell like I
want to bind this text field to this
object I want to do these validations
and and so on all right and then finally
if we have a lot of data we want to show
a listing of it
we can just either pass in a collection
a list of objects to something like a
data grid and have those displayed if we
have a lot of data we can use a callback
interface which will transparently just
keep calling a function that you can
then defer to your back-end database or
rest or some other place where you want
to fetch more data from to the end-user
the experience will be exactly the same
so they keep scrolling it just appear as
if they have just like an infinite data
set very cool so just okay yeah well
yeah we'll get to that but yet
essentially it is so kind of wrapping up
the core concepts here yeah in wahdan
you work with components everything is a
component you lay out these components
by putting them into layouts you add
interaction to this by listening for
events and you do all of this in Java
all right so yep we're gonna build today
is a reactive chat application so where
it's gonna look something like this we
want to have a header here area for
messages then we want to have an input
layout where we can put in our messages
and then obviously we want the messages
to be reflected in real-time to all the
other connected clients I'm gonna use
spring boot for the base of the
application and then we're going to use
spottin for the UI and then we're going
to use project reactor for the reactive
stuff I will give a link to the github
repo after this so you don't need to
like keep a whole lot of notes if you
don't want to and I understand we have a
YouTube recording on on the way as well
so let's jump into code let's see here
please turn on mirroring maybe
older
there we go okay all right so we'll keep
this up here as our kind of spec this is
what we're aiming to do let's make a
little bit bigger I I'm going to start
my project here on I'm on bond calm
slash start and I'm gonna download a
project base with spring this will allow
me to put in some default stuff like the
group ID an app name essentially what
this is going to give us is the same as
if we went to the spring initializer
except that the spring initializer
doesn't have any kind of body an example
code baked in so if you prefer using the
initializer you can you can use that as
well but we'll use this so on all this
lot in chat will download it open it
then once you when your IntelliJ a
license you can open it in IntelliJ ok
so we have it here let's have that and
then the most important thing in the
beginning is getting the font size right
let's see every everyone could see that
in the back too yeah all right so let's
just briefly look at what we have in
here like I said we have a spring boot
application we have the bottom
dependency pulled in here and we have
spring boot dev tools which is going to
reload the application as we're
developing so be a little bit smoother
and then I'll add a project reactor
dependency here so that we get that in
terms of source code we don't have a
whole lot we have a see here
[Music]
there we go so we have a main view like
I said it's mapped to empty route in
this case this would be equal to having
route just an empty route so it's mapped
to the context route
it's an vertical layout so again
recapping what we learned it puts
everything just on top of each other we
have a empty springboard application
class that launches this and let's make
sure that this works so just take out
some of this code we'll put in a h1 here
new h1 nope
yes and then hello and we can just by
calling add we're just adding this to
the vertical layout can remove the
message being here and then just run
this so IntelliJ already notices that
we're in a spring mood application so it
just suggests us to run the application
class here all right
so that'll start up go into browser hit
localhost 8080 see hello Toronto we'll
turn on live reload here which will
hopefully then reload the application as
we're as we're going along all right so
let's take a real quick look at what
rhyming to do the way I want to tackle
this problem is that we're gonna kind of
scaffold out the UI first we're kind of
put everything in place as far as we can
until we get to a point where we need
the backend in order to go forward at
that point we'll jump into the backend
and implement everything that we need
there and then we'll finish up the
application so we'll start by just kind
of putting all the main building blocks
in place and making sure that we get
everything where we need it so instead
of adding you just fix that all right
the first thing I'm gonna do here is if
you look at the kind of layout here you
can see everything is centered so we'll
call set default alignment to Center the
other thing I want to do is set the size
to full what that essentially means is
that we want the layout to expand all
the way to the bottom of our browser
window here the reason being that we
want to put this input layout here at
the bottom
by default the layout would only grow as
much as needed based on the components
that we put in there which is not what
we want in this case all right then
we'll add a new h1 tag Laden chat let's
call this header and then for the header
I'm gonna use this theming API that I
mentioned so there are two variants that
we ship with a light one and dark one if
we switch this to the dark one it's
going to invert the colors and give us
this guy so we're gonna that's going on
here so we're just gonna add dark to the
theme list and then we'll add the header
to our code all right so we'll run this
real quick make this a little bit
narrower we might actually be even able
to kind of see both of these at the same
time maybe all right so it doesn't look
exactly the way we want it one thing
that we can do in an application in
about an application is add a style
sheet so let's add a style sheet well we
can configure a little bit how things
look open up this and then in our Styles
directory here we'll create a new file
style.css
apparently IntelliJ isn't very good at
noticing way I removed the previous one
that I had and then I opened up a new
one with the same name and things all
the same files are still there even
though they're not all right so
styles.css alright and then we're for
main layout h1 so before the h1 will set
set the width to 100% margin to zero
adding 216 pixels like that see alright
run this again hopefully that'll take
care of it know what's going on here oh
yeah of course we need to call that
class name name you so that way alright
once we have the header in place the
next logical thing that we want to do is
ask the user who are you so kind of
identify the user and and so we know
what who they are
so we'll gonna split this into a method
of its own hello look I'll ask user name
and I'll have my ID excuse me have my ID
implement the method for the ask user
name here the UI looks something like
this so we have a text field and then we
have a button next to each other so if
you remember now we're in side of a
vertical layout which meant that if we
put both of those components just
straight into the layout they're just
going to be on top of each other so what
we need to do is we need to nest a
horizontal layout inside of it
create a new horizontal layout call this
make that smaller call this user name
layout and then we'll add that
horizontal layout to our main layout
inside of this we want to add that X
field and the button so we'll create a
new text field
call this user server name field that
will add new button call this start
button give it a caption and then we'll
call user name layout ad and both of
those so user name field and start
button alright
let's build it go back to a browser and
see if we're making some headway what is
going on with this did I
uh-huh
so yeah I forgot to say this is a group
exercise if you see me doing something
incredibly stupid up this one's on you
[Laughter]
alright
oh yeah ma program that's a good one oh
look it worked
alright thank you alright so we're
pretty much right here now the next
thing we want to do is capture that
username information with somebody it's
the start chatting button if you
remember anyone remember how we do that
take the start button and we add a click
listener to it so that way we get
notified whenever somebody clicks on it
click like that in here what we want to
do is first of all we get this user name
field we get the value from it we'll
take that value stick it into a field
what I do I know that's the yeah I'm
super lazy type or so I use a lot of
keyboard shortcuts to have IntelliJ do
most of the heavy lifting once we have
that username safely stored we
essentially don't need this username
layout anymore so what we can do is we
can call remove user name layout so
we'll just kind of trash it we don't
need it anymore and instead we will call
another method here let's call it show
show chat here we're gonna build the
other part of this alright so we'll
build this and then we'll try to figure
out what do you think will happen if we
hit the start chatting button right now
what do we expect will happen yes all
right so we called remove presumably we
have the username stored somewhere in
the field and we have an empty field
here now or an empty screen all right so
we'll get to the next part and it looks
something like this so in the middle we
have a area where we want to have all
the chat messages we have a requirement
for that that is whenever we add a
component new message there we want that
to always get scrolled into view so we
don't want the chat messages just to
kind of disappear so we need to add a
little bit of extra logic to take care
of that and the other requirement we
have is that we want the input layout to
be at the bottom here so again well
start by just putting the components
there then we'll take care of kind of
making them the right size and
everything so I'll create a new
component this kind of common pattern
you'll see in Vaadin applications is
that you take basic components that we
ship with you extend them and then you
add some own logic to them so we'll
create a new one called it message list
message list then we'll implement it
here I will extend just a plain div
that one essentially we don't have a
whole lot of requirements for this it's
just going to be a container but it
needs to scroll to the bottom so well
override the constructor here we'll add
a class name message list so that we can
go in here and set the overflow why to
scroll and while I'm at it I'll just
make this nope so we'll make this 100%
white as well and then I already know
that I'm gonna put in paragraphs in here
for the for the content so we'll do
message list paragraph inside that to be
100% white as well all right so we have
the style so now we know that it will
scroll but of course it doesn't scroll
just by itself we'll need to kind of
instruct it to do it so what we're going
to override from the default behavior of
a div is when we call add we want to
first let the superclass just do its
thing and add the components here well
all we want to do then is we want to
take the last component that was passed
in get the element and call a function
so this is something that's new and
bought in ten plus I don't know if you
used it but essentially we're giving you
kind of access by calling get element
you essentially get the underlying Dom
element which means that we can in this
case we're calling a JavaScript function
on that element so this is one way we
can kind of hook into the underlying
stuff if we ever run into a situation
where the component we're trying to use
doesn't have whatever functionality we
need so here we'll call scroll into view
which is a JavaScript API which will
ensure that it gets crawled into view
all right so that's it just a div which
takes the last added component and makes
sure that that gets crawled into view so
then we'll
add the message list and then we'll
create a input layout I'm essentially
just splitting this into a probably
unnecessarily many pieces just to be a
little bit clearer here again very
similar to what we did for the for the
username layout here we have a text
field and a button next to each other so
we create a new it horizontal layout
this time we'll call this input layout
will return the input layout in here
we'll have the text field for the
message and then we have a send button
and again we had typing too fast for my
own good here all right so we'll take
the input layout we add both of those to
it it's a message field send button all
right a lot of typing again let's hit
play here and see see what happens
so we'll start chatting and kind of see
that we have all the pieces bits and
pieces here but it's not really looking
the way we want it to first of all this
should probably be as wide as the screen
and also it should be all the way here
at the bottom the button was supposed to
be blue so on so well fix some of these
things the way we'll push this to the
bottom and the way we make this text
field bigger than the button is through
the same API called expand so expand
essentially tell us the layout which
component should kind of get all the
extra space that it's not needed by
other components so if we call expand on
message list that tells botton that the
message list should just kind of gobble
up everything else and in the process of
doing that it's gonna push the other
component all the way down until it hits
its bottom so we'll do same thing here
input layout expand on message field in
order for this to have any effect the
input layout needs to be as wide as the
window so this is an alternative if you
don't feel like writing CSS we want to
do something like sets widths or
something you can do it through the Java
API as well all right and then the
button we want it to be blue that's
essentially a theme variant that we have
for a primary button and usually
something that you want to highlight to
the user that this is the primary action
that we expect you to take
we'll call this alright so we'll build
this and yeah there's a in the newest
Vaadin 12 there's a much more convenient
API for setting this I didn't have time
to update it would essentially be set
send button dot set the invariant and
then there's a enum of different themed
variants so you don't have to kind of
know these magical strings anymore
alright so it's all the way here at the
bottom we have a blue button everything
kind of looks very similar to our spec
so that's a good thing alright so now
we're essentially as far as we can go on
this UI before we can go any further we
need to have some place where we can
send the messages and kind of handle all
of that so we'll we'll create a little
bit of back-end code here for that I'm
sorry no placeholder data where we're
going to do this properly alright so
I'll create a new class here it's gonna
be a POJO for a chat message it'll have
information from who it was from
when it was sent what the message was so
we'll we'll create that and in our
application class we'll configure a
couple of beans I'll just use spring
here the way I want to kind of lay this
out is that we'll have a central place
where every kind of chat client can push
their message and this will kind of
broadcast it out to all the connected
clients and they can then kind of do
whatever they need with them so first of
all we'll have a unicast processor for
these chat messages this will be the
central place where we put things all
this it's called publisher and this will
return just a new create that's what I
wanted to do the other part that we want
is something that our chat clients can
subscribe to to get notified the unicast
processor essentially does what we want
has a limitation of only letting one
thing listen to it so if we kind of pipe
in a flux in-between flux being kind of
a thing that can return multiple times
so instead of us just returning a value
once which is kind of a snapshot of that
value in time we can give something back
which will just keep returning over and
over again whenever something happens so
we'll create a flux of chat messages and
the just inject in this unicast
processor here sure and here what we
return is publisher dot replaying so we
will in this simple example we'll just
replay the last 30 messages so if
somebody comes late to the game they'll
get at least a little bit of chat
history and then we'll call Auto Connect
which essentially what it does is it
kind of defers all this set up until
somebody actually does though somebody
actually wants to listen in on this if I
remember correctly this is where I
Springwood dev tools doesn't want to
work so I'll restart the server as
that's going on while it's going on
we'll go into our main view and auto
wire and these two things so we'll have
our unicast processor of chat messages
and then we'll have the flux of chat
messages we will bind these two fields
so we'll have access to them there we go
and what we can do then here is on our
send button we can again add a click
listener and what we want to do when
somebody clicks on this is we want to
essentially get the value from the
message field you want to create a new
chat message and push it to that
publisher so we'll call publisher on
next and then we'll create a new chat
message this takes in two things the
user name who sent it that we already
have because that we saved when the user
came in then the message will be the
message fields value once we have sent
that message while we can
do is we can go ahead and clear that
field for them so that they don't have
to kind of backspace all of this stuff
out so we'll call message field clear
it's also nice if we call message field
okis so that way their focus goes
throughout back in there and they can
continue typing actually be pretty nice
UX if we did that from the get-go so
whenever the user just comes in they can
just start angrily typing in here to
when when arguments Fester all right so
uh build this go into our application
and see what's what's going on all right
start chatting again we'll type
something in here what do we expect to
happen it got cleared and it got focused
so again presumably things went well we
still haven't been able to verify that
the user named guts saved but presumably
since it didn't blow up on us and it did
alright good so we're we're making
progress the next thing is to actually
listen for those messages coming in and
displaying them we will do that in here
so once we've created up our UI
we'll take those that flux and we will
call subscribe on it subscribe we'll get
called whenever a new message comes in
and again this is a demo episode
probably in a real life you wouldn't
want to have this kind of triggered 30
times anytime somebody comes and you
would kind of fetch the history up until
now and then subscribe after that but
for the sake of simplicity this is
what's gonna happen today alright so
once the message comes in will call
message list will call add with a new
paragraph because that's what we made
the CSS for in there we'll take the
message to get from we'll put in a
little separator there and then I just
get message we'll keep it simple just
like who sent it and what was the
message
well again
this going here
demo type in something hello and shows
up here alright this looks good
let's obviously talking to yourself is
it's kind of fun a lot of people out
here seem to be enjoying it so but but
let's see if we can add another chat
line here so we'll go to the localhost
8080 maybe demo - I'll start chatting we
can see that the replay worked we did
get the history up until now and
obviously I I disagree strongly with
this statement from before and this
broke so there is something that we
still need to take care of there's one
kind of obvious thing that we need to
take care of and one less obvious thing
that we need to take care of by default
Baudin just uses a standard xhr ajax
request kind of response model for doing
these updates so whenever we click a
button message gets sent to the server
it figures out what happened then it
updates the UI based on that now with a
chat like this when I'm updating the
u.s. state from here essentially what I
want to do is the server should notify
this other browser window that hey
something happened so we need to take
care of that and anyone think of a good
way that we could accomplish that
WebSocket that's a good thing yeah so
will will enable a WebSocket in button
you do that by adding this push
annotation they'll tell bot in that when
somebody comes in try to establish a
push socket if that fails it'll go
through a whole kind of list of fall
backs and at the end of the day the end
user experience will be the same even if
it might be a little bit longer than the
delay the less kind of obvious thing
that we need to fix here is that since
this chat message comes essentially from
a separate thread from a different
thread as updating the UI button doesn't
like you updating the UI from a separate
thread without you kind of
explicitly saying like hey I know what
I'm doing like let me do this so there's
a axis method that we can use to kind of
pass in a command and that will be run
in a in a kind of thread safe manner
because potentially somebody could be
angrily typing in here at the exact same
time and we could run into weird
situations so what we'll do is here on
the SUBSCRIBE actually here when we
actually change the UI this is the only
part that we need to lock so we'll call
get UI the UI is essentially the central
instance of a Baudin application it's
the browser window if you will call if
present because if this component wasn't
added to the UI yet
it wouldn't essentially have a
associated UI so that's kind of kind of
a bummer that we need to do that but
anyway you IDOT access this is the thing
that takes in the runnable and in here
we can do do things in a safe manner so
we'll move all of this in here that
looks looks okay maybe all right let's
see if that worked
demo chatting
I might need to restart my server here
let's see yep let's restart the server
essentially if everything goes well now
what's going to happen is that when when
we come into the application botton will
establish that WebSocket and it's gonna
happen for both of these windows so
we'll get these up next to each other
like that
demo refresh here demo too
know we can see that this message gets
automatically pushed to all the clients
that are open so if we open up more the
same thing would apply alright very cool
so we built an application all right so
let's go back to our slides and figure
out what just happened first of all if
you want to poke around the code a
little bit kind of on your own time you
can find it here I can post this link to
the meetup page as well so you don't
have to take a picture of it if you
don't want to of course if you want to
take a picture and frame better anything
that's fine all right so if you're
really perceptive during this thing you
might have noticed that oh sorry I'll
I'll sit down I don't want to be
blocking here you might have noticed
that we were writing Java and things
happen in the browser so there probably
some HTML involved there so what was
like what happened in between like what
kind of sorcery was involved in doing
this essentially how Vaadin application
works kind of high-level kind of little
pseudo code but the essential basics are
this when a user comes in
Abbadon the bondage server will provide
it with a bootstrap page that it creates
that bootstrap page will load
essentially those web components
definitions for the components that you
use so in our case the text field and
the button and the vertical layout and
so on the themes for in so they look
nice and then it loads this kind of
rendering engine if you will so we're
not shipping a transpiled version of
your application to be run in the
browser but we're sending a small piece
of JavaScript that knows how to talk to
the server and how to create Dom based
on instructions from the server so it's
a kind of a thin client if you will in
that first message is also the first
render instruction which will be create
these two components here so we interact
with this we'll I'll put in my name I
click the button and in pseudocode it's
not this verbose in real life
what happens is that this javascript in
the browser figures out what just
happened while the button was clicked so
that we need send over also the value
for this text field change so we'll send
that over at the same time Vaughn will
take in this message it will kind of
look at what happened it will first
update the values that it saw had
changed so it will update the text field
value and then there will run the events
so in this case it will trigger this
click listener and in there we can call
this notification that show and when we
called name that get value were assured
that it's already set there so we can
access it as if it had been kind of
running on the server again what happens
is that bottom figures out like since
our last time we updated the ui-hwa has
changed it basically takes a diff and
sends over like hey this is the only
thing that changed you need to add a new
notification component it's value should
be high Marcos and then the javascript
in the browser will take care of
actually creating the Dom and inserting
it into the right place and so on so
that's kind of the basic kind of
high-level of how about an application
works kind of main takeaways is that the
Java code that you write runs into the
JVM we don't generate HTML templates
that we passed back and forth we instead
send these very kind of small render
instructions because they're handled
centrally by Vaadin it means that we can
also switch over to a different protocol
like WebSockets pretty easily and we'll
take a look at some of the other kind of
benefits that we get from from this
alright so just a quick recap of some of
the other features that you get well we
already talked about the automated
communication so again you can use the
WebSockets and if you do you remember to
use the access method one thing that we
didn't really discuss is that you can
these two are kind of equal you would
like by writing that Java code you would
have the exact same code running in the
browser as if you had written the HTML
for the HTML API Bowden has support for
you kind of mixing
matching between declarative and
imperative styles so a lot of times how
that works out is that your designer
gives you this HTML template like this
is the main layout of the application it
needs to look like that you're like
alright alright fine let's do it and
then you just kind of plug in where the
view goes you can generate forms and
stuff in in Java in there so you can
kind of mix and match between these two
stuff I like I mentioned and we kind of
briefly looked at this bond has a
support for theming let's take a look at
a more real-life example of that so
we'll mirror again here close this I
will open up one of our demo apps big
URI flow the Bakery app is essentially
our little demo app that just shows all
the components in a natural environment
for them just so you can get a better
sense for the types of applications that
you would be able to build with this so
it's kind of very standard business app
you have a lot of a lot of forms and
fields and lots of data if we open up
the inspector here sorry taking a quick
step away from Java lend if you're if
you don't want to see HTML you can close
your eyes for a second I'll let you know
what the one thing that we can and this
see if this works better yeah
well we gotta make her money somehow
all right so we'll uh let's take a quick
look at one of these components just to
kind of let you see so you can see like
what's running in the browser is exactly
this modern text field component that we
had from from before but the theming API
is something that's pretty cool so if we
said the theme here too dark this is
essentially the same thing that we did
in our application for that header but
now I'm setting it for the entire
application what happens is that it
applies to every single component in our
application so you can see that it
applied to everything also exposes a
whole bunch of these different CSS
properties that we can change so let's
take a look at something like
border-radius so right now you can maybe
perhaps he is like a very very slight
little roundness to those corners but we
could like go crazy and have it like be
super round like that or we could maybe
go and have it just super square if we
wanted to we can also change things like
colors so if we take some of the base
colors like here and change the entire
kind of component set in one go so if we
wanted to have a nice purple UI I forgot
to say that I'm not I'm not a designer
I'm not authorized to show this when our
designers are in the room batise anyway
you get the idea so the idea yes yes
the the idea those that you can by
changing these parameters you can make
the components that look very close to
what you need it to be and then you can
add some own your own CSS on top of it
in addition to these two variants light
and dark we also ship with a material
design theme so if you're if you're
really into material design you can do
that as well like I mentioned all the
components are accessible we spend a lot
of time ensuring that they work nice
with keyboards with screen readers and
such it's obviously a nice thing to do
for everyone but if you're working in
big companies financial government stuff
it's not a nice-to-have feature it's
something that's kind of a baseline
requirement for anything that you're
building the architecture that we have
where the app is running on the server
and essentially what's running in the
browser is a thin client is very strong
from a security perspective because
essentially you're not exposing any of
the app internals to the external world
so any amount of looking into that
rendering engines not gonna really tell
anyone too much inner interesting stuff
about your application it's not gonna
expose any rent endpoints or anything
else it actually goes a little bit
further and does kind of basic sanity
checks on data so for instance you say
you have a crud view where only admins
can delete stuff and some smart guy was
kind of just recording all the traffic
and figured out what the message should
be to trigger this button if they sent
that to the server and weren't the admin
what would happen is that bada notices
that like an invisible button is trying
to get triggered and just throw an
invalid state exception so it's kind of
it knows what should be doable and what
shouldn't be doable at any given time so
this is the reason why button is kind of
very heavily used in in like financial
and healthcare and government and other
places as well
in addition to the fact that we have a
fairly stable API again this stems from
the fact that we've kind of put a very
strict API separation between the java
api that you work in as developers and
then how we implement that API in the
browser so if you think about like a
button as a concept doesn't change all
that much over time so when we started
out eighteen years ago
the bunts API in Java is essentially
exactly the same as it is today but the
way we've implemented that in the
browser has changed several several
times over the years and like I
mentioned now it's using these latest
kind of web standards for web components
but that gives you kind of a way of
building modern web applications without
having to kind of rebuild them every six
or so months or however often front and
frameworks tend to break their api's
also since baudin does run on the JVM
it's unlike say if you've ever used like
google web toolkit back in the day that
kind of transpired into into into
JavaScript which meant that you had kind
of a limited subset of the Java API
available to you since we're running on
the JVM it means that you kind of get
everything that to JVM offer so you can
work with alternative languages I heard
several of Scala developers here we have
a lot of Scala developers in our company
to Kotlin we have a DSL for that one of
our developers for that any kind of
testing tools any kind of profilers and
anything that IDs that you like you can
use with Vardon we take care of making
sure that Vaadin works in all the
browsers that we support so we run
thousands of tests every night even down
to like comparing screenshots of the
components between different
permutations of operating systems and
browsers making sure that like things
just work so if you build your
application you don't have to like spend
a whole lot of time just trying to
figure out like why doesn't this thing
work and in edge or whatever the
browsers that we support are I 11 and up
and then any actual browser button is
also built to be extendable so obviously
even though we come with a very big
library of components we can like fit
everyone's every need in the world we
already took a look at some ways we can
extend Vaadin like for instance we
extended one of the base components and
added some
functionality to what we called some
Java Script API isn't it we can also
take any existing like web components or
JavaScript components and just give them
about an API very simply through this
element API and says it's an open source
project there are a lot of community
contributed ready-made components if you
don't feel like doing it yourself so if
you need like a google map component or
charting library or whatever you need
there's a very good chance that
somebody's already done that work for
you and you don't have to actually do it
yourself
all right in closing a couple words on
on Bawden as a company we've been around
for about 18 years I think now we kind
of always had the focus on building apps
on the web in Java
we're originally a Finnish company like
I'm I'm from Finland the name itself
means reindeer and Finnish so that's
where the logo comes from if you like
the logo we have some laptop stickers
over here you can come and grab them
afterwards we have offices in besides
Finland we have one in Berlin and one in
California where I live
the way we make money essentially mostly
based on professional services so people
companies who need help with like
building a custom component or help
augmenting their team building a lot an
application or getting training stuff
like that that's kind of our bread and
butter right there we do have a couple
of commercial add-ons that we offer for
instance a charting library or a kind of
a drag-and-drop UI builder tool for kind
of cranking out form Sona on an assembly
line if you're interested in checking it
out you can go to the starter page that
I used when I got started with the app
there Vaughn comm slash start and with
that I'll open up for questions yes sir
is there my session state where you're
keeping like where yeah so it Martin
uses the session for storing state so
typically in a kind of button setup you
would use sticky sessions so you kind of
just route people to the one instance
that's kind of the easiest way you can
you can do replication but it tends to
be kind of yeah anyway yeah yeah and
typically like the session is still like
fairly lightweight so especially if
you're building something that's like
more internal facing or something that's
like less than a couple of 1000 of
thousands of like users it's it's really
not a big deal scaling stuff if you're
building kind of the next Gmail kind of
scale then this probably isn't the best
tool for that but well yeah so at this
moment with with the API that we have
like that we use right now it's only
working off online you could define an
offline fallback page so you could have
a nicer experience when somebody does go
offline but that's really that's going
to be one of the big themes for us next
yearís adding better support for
progressive web applications and we
really want to become kind of the
easiest way for somebody on a JVM stack
to build a really great progressive web
app so that's something that you should
definitely kind of check out yes sir
we used to like up until one night we
used to use SAS but now we're we
switched over to using CSS custom
properties and just kind of it gives us
most of the kind of same functionality
without having to require a separate
build step in between so you can still
have like sent and globally defined
variables and stuff but yeah not
completely standalone or at least that's
like as far as I know you can't run like
the backend part of an electron app
needs to be node of course you could
kind of render just use it as a frame to
render to but in that case it would be
probably easier to you just kind of do
like a installable PWA for instance
which would be a much lighter weight
option than wrapping it an electron I
think I had a question behind you as
well can you repeat the question not
sure yeah sure so if you're using the
java api it's going to run on the server
but like i said you can use all the same
components so if you if you want to
build an entirely like client-side
application that doesn't have any
connection to a server that could call
any kind of server less functions or
anything that could be done and you
could kind of do the exact same
application but then you couldn't take
advantage of that java api yes sir
browsers api's like the storage API is
in the database that exists in the
browser second wait Java code and like
store stuff there and cache it that's
also a part of the kind of upcoming PWA
support stuff that you can you can
through the kind of JavaScript Interop
api so you can do that but like since it
doesn't really run offline if you build
it this way as a as a Java API it it's
not as useful right now to our users as
it will be in the future yes it
definitely took longer than this like
what people don't necessarily realize is
that in order for live chat like hacking
to kind of be be not painful to look at
it needs to be fairly choreograph babe
it didn't take that long because just
because I've been I've been working at
button for like eight years I pretty
much know the framework inside and
outside I I had a vision and I knew how
to build it like it all right um this is
my Twitter handle so if you come up with
good questions afterwards you can feel
free to hit me up on Twitter
I'll also hang out here after it after
the talk so if you want to come and like
grill me some more feel free to do that
and yeah thanks thanks guys for hosting
me
[Applause]